over land and sea through Sun and snow a
winter buying travels over 600 miles
just for testing so why is it so special
at eight megawatts the v16 ball from
bestest just became the world's most
powerful to be king of the turbines you
need height at 220 meters it's two
Statue of Liberty's height to spin major
blades so you catch the most wind
possible the v16 four covers 20,000
square meters that's the same as three
football pitches while only a prototype
this machine is likely to be built out
at sea that's where it can most
effectively work converting stronger
more persistent wind at larger sites
Fester's say the bigger the better more
power means fewer unnecessary costs when
it comes to cabling and repairs then
again if one of these giants goes
offline at the hands of vicious winds
waves that's even more energy lost - but
it's machines like this that
manufacturers like Vestas hope will
bring down the cost of renewable energy
if they're right don't expect the v16
for to hold a crown or world's most
powerful turbine - much longer Tom
Gibson Bloomberg
Oh